here's a
article from The Daily Mail says Netflix
has quietly canceled a woke animated
kids show which features a bison who
comes out as non-binary to its
grandmother
Ridley Jones released its Fifth and
final season last week which was not
given any promotion according to
according to the show's Creator uh Chris
knee the two-time kids screen Award
winner and Emmy nominee series received
harsh criticism online following the
release of episode 8 of season 5 called
herd day which centers around a bison
called Fred who comes out as non-binary
to their grandmother who's voiced by
Sydney Loper
some viewers blasted the show on Twitter
claiming Fred's non-binary identity was
slipped into the show's narrative
so okay so the series is called Ridley
Jones
about a bison I've never even heard of
this show before
one viewer asked quote do your kids
watch Ridley Jones it features a female
bison who identifies as neither male nor
female and wants to be referred to as
they them pronouns quietly slipped in
there drip drip drip what a message to
send to young girls in particular
the Creator who's a lesbian mom
addressed the cancellation in a tweet
last Wednesday says doesn't surprise me
that Netflix has quietly dumped the
first preschool show that has a
non-binary character coming out I
realize in this day and age dumped means
many things just zero promotion of the
episode
first of all I'm pretty sure this is not
unfortunately I wish I could say that
this was the first preschool show that
has a non-binary character I'm pretty
sure that's not the case in the not too
distant past private citizens used to be
largely that they used to be private if
you could believe it what's changed well
the internet has changed a lot of things
think about everything you've ever
searched for watched or tweeted on the
internet now imagine all of that data
being crawled through collected
aggregated by Third parties into
permanent public records
to keep my data private when I go online
I use expressvpn there are hundreds of
data Brokers out there whose sole
business involves buying and selling
your data they don't even have to tell
you who they're selling it to or get
your consent one of these data points is
your IEP address data Harvesters use
your IP to uniquely identify you and
also your your precise physical location
but you can mask your IP address with
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection through an encrypted server
which makes it more difficult for third
parties to find me sounds complicated
but at least on your end it really isn't
all you do is open the app Tap a button
and uh simple as that you're you're safe
you're good to go stop letting people
keep logs of what you do online use
MyLink expressvpn.com Matt walshow today
and get three months free on on a one
year package that's exp r e s s vpn.com
Matt wall show expressvpn.com Matt Walsh
show I mean they've got you know they're
doing a
Pride parades and drag queens in Blues
Clues now so this is ground that has
been shred before but I think we have
the clip from the show let's watch that
that's because I'm non-binary and Fred
is the name that fits me best and I also
use they and them because calling me a
she or a he doesn't feel right to me I'm
sorry I used the wrong name and real
names
well yes exactly as we exactly as we
were told a uh
a non-binary bison in the kids show
and it is uh it's it is at least
encouraging
that this show is a total flop and now
it's being quiet and of course Netflix
isn't going to make a big scene about it
but um
it's a flop people aren't interested
people don't want this and now they have
to cancel the show that is that is
encouraging
because as much as uh you know we have a
problem with woke parents who want to uh
indoctrinate their kids into this what
we see is that still the vast majority
of parents do not want this they're not
interested in it
and that includes plenty of parents who
otherwise might be mistakenly okay with
some of this kind of stuff
there are probably still and this this
is uh changing as the world crowd
becomes ever more radicalized by the day
but there are still plenty of parents
who would say something like well uh you
know the non-binary I support that
you know they would legitimize the idea
being non-binary but they still
they're not going to sit their kid down
to watch a show with that stuff in it
and then there's also a group of parents
who who would support that and might
even say that they would sit their kids
down to watch something like this but
then in reality they're not going to
um so that's the positive anyway
and I'll do it for the show today as we
uh move over to the members block if you
want to join us for that you can become
a member and use code walls to check out
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]